le nougat glacé au miel local le dr
proposé au menu de la prochaine
quinzaine gourmande dans cet
établissement
et pour cette 14e édition les trente six
restaurateurs eurelia impliqué joue les
prolongations deux semaines au lieu
d'une on s'est rendu compte que certains
de nos collègues n'avaient pas la
capacité à accueillir tous les clients
qu'il l'aurait souhaité
donc on a étendu la période est d'autant
plus qu'avec la distanciation de
certaines tables en les restaurant
sabilité le nombre de places assises
ici le qu'ovide 19 n'a pas fait
qu'imposer les gestes barrière le
déconfinement venu il a fallu s'adapter
pour ré alimenter la trésorerie à la mi
mai le restaurant s'est donc mis à la
vente à emporter une nouvelle pratique
qui répond à toutes les situations
comme on aime bien que c'est très bon la
vente à emporter
vous avez des mamans qui ne se disent
tiens ce soir je ne vais rien faire à la
maison je passe prendre une vente
emporté au bergerac
ça peut être également des gens de
travail qui ont une pause qui est
réduite le midi ils viennent prendre un
plat ils n'auront plus qu'à leur mettre
en température et mangés au bureau après
la période estivale et avant les fêtes
de fin d'année le mois d'octobre est
généralement calme pour le chiffre
d'affaires des restaurateurs avoir une
opération culinaires comme la quinzaine
pour montre à cette période
c'est l'occasion de maintenir les
finances à flot mais avec la crise
sanitaire actuelle la certitude est
aussi présente
moi je pense que là le dur il est il est
à venir devant là parce que là il y
avait des terrasses donc ça a très bien
marché
qu'est ce qui va se passer à partir de
cet automne sans terrasse je sais pas
l'an dernier l'opération plus linéaire a
permis de vendre quatre mille repas en
neuf jours en cette année compliquée les
restaurateurs d'eure-et-loir espère
éveiller davantage de papilles